this is what russian president vladimir
putin unleashed on ukraine
this is how some news organizations in
the u.s have been covering russia's
invasion of ukraine russia's full-scale
invasion russian invasion russia
attacking ukraine's fuel deposits
and this is how it's described on
russian state television
the two sides they really have wildly
different descriptions of what's going
on because the kremlin is really
conscious of public opinion
state broadcasters have been reinforcing
russian president vladimir putin's
narrative that ukraine and its western
allies pose threats to his country
ukraine
with ongoing global coverage of the war
and a deluge of information on social
media russian state media outlets are
using maps and dismissing western media
reports to send its own message about
the invasion of its next door neighbor
[Music]
to understand why putin decided to
attack you first need to know how he
sees ukraine's relationship to russia
so the state media has been giving its
viewers a geography lesson
this is a map of ukraine today which was
a soviet state before it gained its
independence in 1991.
here parts of the country are broken up
into sections the reporter says that
these areas aren't really ukraines but
were gifts from past russian and soviet
leaders and this yellow part in the
middle is the only section that's
labeled as ukrainian territory maps like
these the idea is to really shape public
opinion and give this this kind of
historical backing for their current
operation in ukraine
and this historical context was
reiterated in putin's nearly hour-long
speech days before the invasion
[Music]
putin
seems to have been focused on history
when it comes to ukraine and he has
always
mentioned ukraine where it has been part
of russia and
it should continue to be part of russia
back in 1991 ukrainians held a
referendum that overwhelmingly supported
independence from the soviet union and
this decision was backed by russia and
as a sovereign state several years later
ukraine asked to join nato but putin
objected because this would bring the
military alliance closer to russia's
doorstep a concern that his predecessor
shared after the breakup of the soviet
union
so he demanded that the alliance
guarantee ukraine would not get
membership and when there were none
the state media has amplified this
narrative that the conflict with ukraine
isn't russia's fault but the u.s and its
western allies are to blame
a few days after the invasion putin
raised the stakes again
he ordered the country's nuclear forces
to be put on alert as the u.s and its
allies stepped up pressure with new
sanctions
and russian state media echoed his
message
nada state media programs are also
running disinformation segments this
newscast shows what it claims to be a
tweet from cnn about an american who
died during the invasion of ukraine no
american casualties have been reported
during the war and the twitter account
was suspended cnn said the tweet was
fabricated and the account not
affiliated with the news organization in
any way the russian state media channel
russia24 didn't respond to a request for
comment
russian state media have also repeated
the kremlin's position that there are no
threats to civilians and that it's only
targeting military installations
in the first week of war ukrainian
officials said the invasion's civilian
death toll had reached 2 000.
these outlets they're propagating you
know the kremlin line that this is a
limited operation and also saying that
russia needs to demilitarize ukraine
they're really saving the population in
eastern ukraine the kremlin wants that
the the domestic audience sees russia
not as an aggressor
before the invasion many russians agreed
with the kremlin line on ukraine about
60 of those surveyed in russia say
tensions in ukraine are the fault of the
u.s and nato according to a russian
independent pollster
but the kremlin's narrative isn't
getting to everyone in russia
across the country people have been
protesting putin's decision to invade
so to continue shaping public opinion
the country's communications regulator
ordered all media outlets including
independent ones to only use official
government sources the government
watchdog and state media organizations
didn't respond to a request for comment
and as the west has started to cut off
russia from the global financial system
ordinary citizens are starting to feel
the pain lining up at atms to pull out
cash as the russian currency has
plummeted
is and this could provide the kremlin
another opportunity to cast the us and
its allies as russia's aggressors as the
war in ukraine continues